حسناً يعني نحن نقف حيث وقفنا دائماً
في الأردن
أه تحقيق
السلام الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي هو
أه شرط
لتحقيق السلام الشامل الذي
نريده جميعاً ندرك التحديات التي
نعرف أن
حل الدولتين يجري
تقوضها
مرة أخرى إجراءات غير شرعية من شأنها أن
تجعل قابلية ذلك الحل
قابلاً للتطبيق أه يتآكل
تمامًا هكذا سيستمر العمل مع
شركاء في المنطقة في
أوروبا ومع الإدارة الأمريكية الجديدة
التي بعثت
أه العديد من الإشارات الإيجابية حتى الآن لإعادة
الأمل  و و و و امض قدما ان
قالت اه
الانتخابات
هي فترة جمود
لا يوجد فيها قرارات رئيسية أه يتم اتخاذها عادة
هذا تحد واحد
والتحدي الآخر أه
شفقة السياسة والانتخاب
الذي يتجلى على أه أكثر عدوانية
مرة أخرى مثل توسيع المستوطنات
بوتيرة لم نشهد منذ
سنوات خطابًا
لا يلتزم بالأرض.  أم
معادلة السلام التي كانت هي الأساس
الذي بدأ عليه مجهود السلام كله
وأقصد القمار
أه
بحقوق شعوب المنطقة وكل
دول المنطقة في العيش بسلام
وأمان من
أجل أغراض انتخابية مرة أخرى
أه وضع تلك الأجندات  أمام
أه مرة أخرى حق كل الناس
حتى السلام والكرامة فهذه
تحديات كبرى
لمقاومة الشيء الوحيد الذي
يجب القيام به هو الاستمرار مع أه
موضحين
أن هذا اللعب بالنار
وهذا خطر على جميع الأطراف.
الإسرائيليون الفلسطينيون المنطقة
والعالم الهند ككل
كان جلالة الملك عبد الله
وولي العهد
في الرياض في وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع لمراجعة
العلاقات
بين البلدين ومناقشة
التعاون المشترك ، كانت هناك
تقارير تفيد بأنه إذا قامت المملكة العربية السعودية
بتطبيع العلاقات مع  إسرائيل أن
مصير أحد أقدس الأماكن في الإسلام هو
المسجد الأقصى
الذي يكون الأردن
خادمًا له.
التي تقول ما الذي سأقوله بشكل جيد ،
ببساطة لا أرى
أين سبب
هذا النوع من الافتراضات غير المنطقية ،
فإن الوصاية الهاشمية
على
الأماكن المقدسة الإسلامية المسيحية في القدس هي
وصاية تاريخية تعود إلى
العظمة.  جد جلالة
الملك هي وصاية تحظى
بدعم جميع الدول العربية الإسلامية بل
في العالم لأنها
تلعب دورًا مهمًا للغاية في
الحفاظ على الوضع الراهن
في الأماكن المقدسة والحفاظ على
الهوية العربية المسيحية لتلك المواقع
والحفاظ عليها.
ومحاولة الحفاظ على القدس
كمدينة سلام للجميع ،
لدينا علاقة ممتازة مع
المملكة العربية السعودية ، فنحن ننسق
في القضية الفلسطينية كما نفعل في
قضايا أخرى ويستمر هذا التنسيق ،
لذا فإن من يقوم بهذا الافتراض
هو في الحقيقة لا يؤسسهم.
على أي أه معقول أه دلالة
أو
قادمة من أه
إشاعات متوافرة بكثرة أه أه مثل هذه النظريات
أه  التآمر مهجور لكن
الحقيقة أن
السعودية تدعم
الوصاية الهاشمية والوصاية الهاشمية
لأنها
تاريخية متجذرة في التاريخ أه
مقبول ويصادق عليه
الفلسطينيون
ومعترف به من قبل المسيحيين العرب لدورها المهم.
والمسلمين في جميع أنحاء
العالم والمجتمع الدولي بالفعل
دعني أسألكم أن ولي العهد الأردني هذا
قد التقى
بهدف زيارة المسجد الأقصى هذا
الأسبوع لكنه
ألغى الرحلة بسبب الخلاف حول
ترتيبات الأمن والسلامة في
الموقع
ما حدث لوزير الخارجية حسنًا.  ما
حدث ببساطة هو أن
صاحب السمو الملكي أراد الذهاب لأداء
الصلاة
في المسجد الأقصى في مناسبة مقدسة للمسلمين
طوال ليلة إسرائيل وكانت زيارة
دينية
للأقصى
وإلى بعض الكنائس في القدس.
وكذلك قمنا
بترتيبات مع إسرائيل
فيما يتعلق بالوصول إلى الأقصى
في اللحظة الأخيرة ، تراجعت إسرائيل عن تلك
الاتفاقات التي حاولت
أه إغير البرنامج وأه
حاول فرض إجراءات من شأنها أن تفرض
المزيد من القيود على المقدسيين في
مثل هذه
الليلة المقدسة للعبادة والسلام
والقداسة أه لذا قرر سموه
ألا
يمضي أه في تلك الزيارة لإنقاذ
الناس من  القدس أه ثقل
المزيد من القيود الإسرائيلية من أجل
حماية
مثل هذه المناسبة المقدسة أه
ومن انتهاك
حرماتها أه صفاءها وطبيعتها السلمية
نكثت إسرائيل بالاتفاق
الذي أبرمناه معهم
أنهم خالفوا التزاماتهم
كقوة محتلة
وانتهكوا الحق في حرية
العبادة وهذا شيء
نحن أه غير راضين
عنه
وغاضبين منه أه مرة أخرى زيارة دينية
إلى أه للعبادة في
مناسبة مقدسة للغاية
أه تعطلت بسبب
الصور الإسرائيلية التي نقوم بها  لا
أفهم ولا نقبل
أن رئيس وزراء إسرائيل كان من المقرر
أن يقوم برحلة تاريخية
إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة حيث أنا ولكني قررت
النشر
ألقي باللوم في اللحظة الأخيرة على
السلطة الأردنية مشيرة إلى
صعوبات في تنسيق
رحلته عبر الأجواء الأردنية
هل هذا صحيح أه
إنك أه تراجعت عن اتفاق مع
الأردن عطل زيارة دينية
أه أنت أه أه أوجدت الظروف التي
جعلت هذا  أه هذه الزيارة الدينية المقدسة
أه في مناسبة مقدسة
مستحيلة وبعدها تتوقع أن تأتي
إلى
الأردن وتخرج من الأردن
فلنكن جادين هنا هل هذا شيء
يمكن توقعه